helgoland ich glaube es nicht richtig zu
erinnern dass gerade der pressekonferenz
sind sie auf die frage nicht eingegangen
eingegangen ob es ein gerücht gäbe dass
frau titel mit einigen frisch gewählten
abgeordneten eine eigene fraktion bilden
halten sie das für möglich das weiß ich
nicht das wird man sehen
mir wird gesagt dass die abgeordneten
nicht wollen aber ich kann das nicht
voraussehen also ich werde dazu nichts
sagen rechnen ich weiß nicht weiß ist
ein großer verlust sie hat ja immerhin
ein direktmandat eins von drei
direktmandaten für die afg geholt frauke
petry und im land niedersachsen
entscheidung im land sachsen zum ersten
mal hat eine partei nach baden
württemberg die grünen dort die position
der stärksten partei ist das ein großer
verlust für die afg und ihre
durchschlagskraft also es ist immer ein
verlust wenn jemand der auch gute arbeit
geleistet hat geht das ist völlig klar
zweitens ich habe mich im wahlkampf
nicht sehr unterstützt gefühlt von
frauke petry verwaltet und ich haben
eine menge termine übernommen die sie
plötzlich abgesagt hat und dass man
seinen spitzenteam drei tage vor der in
val entscheidung in der leipziger
volkszeitung angreift macht die sache
noch schlechter von daher bin ich sehr
skeptisch
das ist nun nur ein verlust ist aber wir
müssen auch mal eins gerade rücken ich
bilde mir nicht ein dass ich mein gutes
ergebnis in brandenburg um ihr zu
verdanken habe
und das sächsische ergebnisse ist auch
nicht nur frauke petry zu verdanken
sondern es ist der arbeit des
spitzenteams unter einschluss der
jeweiligen spitzenkandidaten der länder
zu verdanken
da können sie ja zum beispiel auch
bayern nehmen wo es ein sehr gutes
ergebnis für unsere verhältnisse gab
also sachsen ist ein sonderfall
schon durch die pga stärke in dresden
da ist die unzufriedenheit
größten insofern muss man das alles
relativieren und wir haben fahrweise und
ich ein ergebnis erzielt von dem vor
kurzem herr schäuble noch gesagt hat
naja vielleicht kommen die gar nicht in
den bundestag
und das ist nicht jetzt frauke petry es
arbeit war sie mit großem aplomb hier
aus der bundespressekonferenz abgezogen
ist hat sie noch gesagt sie vermisse
programmatische inhalte in der partei
das müsse besser werden
sie hat das gefordert dann daraus
schließt man ja eigentlich dass es zu
wenig programmatische diskussionen in
der afg gibt das verstehe ich nun gar
nicht denn wir haben sowohl ein
grundsatzprogramm wie ein wahlprogramm
an dem hat sie mitgearbeitet und wenn
dazu wenig programmatik in weiß ich
nicht wie viele seiten drin ist dann
hätte sie dass ihr irgendwann einmal
sagen können das hat sie aber nie gesagt
das höre ich heute zum ersten mal
stattdessen habe es statt der
programmatischen diskussion und inhalte
jede menge abwegiger äußerungen in der
partei gegeben war das auf sie gemünzt
das weiß ich nicht was sie für abhängige
äußerungen hält
ich kann nur sagen man muss sehr
vorsichtig mit solchen vorwürfen sein
denn andre poggenburg in sachsen anhalt
ist zusammen mit der cdu etwas gelungen
was nun doch ihrem realpolitischen
vorstellungen entspricht und der wird
auch immer wegen angeblich unabhängigen
äußerungen kritisiert also ich sehe
nicht so recht was wir hätten besser
machen sollen
und ich sehe nicht so recht was anderes
gemacht worden wäre wenn frau gebiet wie
mehr einfluss gehabt hätte aber sie hat
nun mal als vorsitzende als nummer eins
enormen einfluss ob ich den nutzer oder
nicht nutze das ist
ihre sache sie hat gesagt sie habe immer
dafür gekämpft in der afg dass möglichst
bald eine regierungsübernahme möglich
ist so bis zur nächsten bundestagswahl
in etwa war das eine position mit der
sie in der afg auf zustimmung gestoßen
ist
das weiß ich nicht wir hatten eigentlich
immer dasselbe verständnis nur auf
augenhöhe in koalitionen zu gehen weil
kleinere partner in der alten
bundesrepublik von der cdu immer
untergebuttert worden sind dh
da waren wir uns eigentlich immer einig
das ist auch das was uns die uns
wirklich freundschaftlich verbundene
partei fpö empfohlen hat von daher
verstehe ich nicht dass das jetzt
plötzlich ein thema ist ich sehe das
nicht anders regierungsverantwortung
erst wenn wir auf augenhöhe mit den
anderen sinn das hat sie bis jetzt auch
immer vertreten
wenn sie da heute was anderes
vertreibung kann ich nichts dafür gehört
eine partei vorsitzende frauke petry mit
dem heutigen tag der vergangenheit an
das weiß ich nicht das muss der pater
bestimmen der parteitag takt irgendwann
ende november anfang dezember
alexander gauland im phoenix interview
herzlichen dank dass sie daran